so here's barack obama
yesterday on a live talking about
defunding the police and here's what he
had to say about
eve as i do that we should be able to
reform the criminal justice system so
that
it's not biased and treats everybody
fairly i guess you can use a snappy
slogan like defund the police
but you know you've lost a big audience
the minute you say it which makes it a
lot less likely that you're actually
going to get the changes you want done
but if you instead say let's reform the
police department so that everybody's
being treated fairly you know divert
young people from getting into crime and
if there's a homeless guy can maybe we
send a mental health worker there
instead of an armed
unit that could end up resulting in a
tragedy suddenly a whole bunch of folks
who might not
otherwise listen to you are listening to
you so the key is deciding do you want
to actually get something done
or do you want to feel good among the
people you already agree with paul if
you want to get something
okay go ahead that that's a politician
right there he knows what he's doing
you know it's a strategy yeah and it
scares me that that sound by
terrifies me because up until this point
i thought barack obama was about as far
left as you can get
he certainly was as president and he's
being called out by the far far left
they hate him i mean they hate that
comment they're saying you know they're
fighting him on that which means
the radicalness extends so far beyond
him it's it's frightening
he's just a smooth dude man i think what
we're seeing right now like tom just
said
i never thought that obama was too far
far far left i think of myself
as a moderate center left person on the
on the you know socially stuff certainly
i'm a little more left
on on economy stuff i'm a little where
is obama where's obama i think he's
center a little bit to the left no i
don't think that's the case
i think he's on the 40-yard line oh no
no dude he's a reasonable dude man i
don't
i don't use that the problem that i have
is when people are like
he's a communist he is a socialist wow
he's a russian uh he's from africa like
i immediately
obama would not admit to being on the
40-yard line i'd say he's on the 20.
he's on the 20-yard line he's probably
20-25-yard line that's where he's at by
the way
ilhan omar aoc there she's ridiculous
she she's in the upper deck
past the end so like as someone who
votes for uh biden or obama i don't like
those
people so go to ilhan omaro and show the
tweet that she just tweeted after seeing
this video she flipped out
here's what she had to say uh do you
have the tweet or no
we lose people in the hands of police
it's not a slogan but a policy demand
uh adam we lose people in the hands of
police
it's not a slogan but a policy demand
and centering the demand for equitable
investments and budgets for communities
across the countries gets us progress
and safety
that's infuriating she's an idiot why
are we listening to her here's what's
here's what's here's what's even bigger
than
infuriating 124 thousand people like
that tweet
she's from minnesota do you understand
the crime problems a minute you're
people todd i know i cannot believe it
you voted that's where
the police started what's going on with
your people tomorrow but
you know what how are you jackson's up
like three thousand depends
how do you do it it's literally
dangerous to be in minneapolis right now
that used to be one of the safest places
in the world people were so nice i mean
it was harmless
carjackings through the roof you cannot
go to certain parts of town you will get
mugged in the middle of the day
they had to have an emergency meeting of
the minneapolis city council
to add 500 000 to the budget to bring in
outside help from the suburbs for the
police force because so many of the cops
have taken early retirement she is so
dangerous she need
why are we forced to listen to her why
have we ordained her as the voice of the
left
what's funny is i very rarely i mean
what do you mean what do you mean force
listener i don't know
how about the word that she put in her
tweet i don't know at all we demand
right
what are you doing demanding you got
reelected so there's people in minnesota
that like what you have to say
i for one don't listen to her don't
necessarily like what she stands for
people in minnesota i don't know we'll
have to find out why they like her so
much
i'm not a fan not a fan but
unfortunately she has a voice and people
like what she has to say
not a fan though so going back to obama
talking about defunding that's a smooth
dude
so go back to obama and talk about
defending the police hey you know what
what is wrong with what he said here's
what's wrong so the the
all three sides here's what they're
saying is wrong with it
the one side the right is saying
he's saying that but he doesn't believe
that
meaning he believes in defunding the
police but he's going about it to say in
a different way because if you really do
want to find a way to defund the police
that's how you say it the way obama said
it but he really wants to defund the
police so that's what many of the people
on the far right are saying
on the far left they're saying what
shame on you for saying something like
that
we made all this progress on defunding
the police and you're hurting us
the folks in the middle are saying what
he's reasonable you know he's reasonable
for what he said yeah
the point i'm trying to make to you is
going back to that phone call whoever
made the phone call to say
shut down the economy so we can send the
mail and balance there has to be
somebody as strategic as brilliant
as him who knows how to reason
this guy is a genius like his policies
or not
obama's an absolute genius of a
strategist
and a guy you have to be naive to not
say this guy's a genius obama's a genius
have you also noticed how his profile
has gone so much higher now
after november third i mean he was
laying very very low sold 1.7 million
copies his first week record breaking no
one's ever sold 1.7 million copies in a
week
and as we learned even the publishing
industry has changed because of that
book
because they have to spend so many
resources printing that book that other
books get backed up but they can't even
bring books number two book in the world
right now number one your next five
moves by pvd congratulations you beat
obama that's amazing yeah so
so the point is that this is a guy that
if you
if you don't if i have somebody that i
want to be able to give
feedback to see what to do things with
that's a guy and by the way when you're
saying he's 35-yard line he's not
35-yard line because on the inside if
you read his book and his story
with his father his upbringing what he
really what his father believed in
there's a lot of emotions behind him the
benefit he has is he's very poised
he has this gift of poise and it gives
him a lot of power
so even if behind closed doors you're
saying he's closer to the 30 yard line
25 year old
he has the ability to to get to the
people on the 50-yard line to get people
on the other 40 yards that's
what i'm saying say come on over here
that's all i'm saying over here yes
you know he has a major problem he's a
converter
he's a converter of the independent
party yeah and that's what you need to
do in order to win hillary wasn't a
to the independent party you know yeah
he was a conversation here let me ask
you a question yeah
do you think slash do you like the fact
that he's going to be in biden's ear you
know everyone thinks that biden's you
know decrepit dementia dude
you know i'll give see there we go
there's that bias we love that but
he can play with his dog without
breaking multiple bones he's got a bum
leg
um do you like the fact that he's that
obama is going to be in his ear saying
hey man here's here's what i would do in
this situation
here's what i recommend here's my advice
a do you think he will be in his ear b
do you like the fact that he'll be in
his ear
he's going to be in his ear do i like
the fact that he's going to be in his
ear yeah i don't mind the fact that he's
going to be in this year i think it's
good for him to be in his ear all i'm
saying is i don't even think biden's
going to be making the decisions as a
president listen
there are certain people that do
what they want to do trump trump's going
to do what trump's going to do
ain't nobody going to tell them what to
do for good or bad it's it's for good or
for bad it's not a good thing or bad
thing it can haunt you
but it's also a good thing okay if
you're right then there are certain
people that
do what others tell them what to do okay
like hillary clinton
like biden no not really hillary clinton
is going to do what hillary clinton's
going to do she's also a maverick
no way biden people are going to tell me
biden what to do
was very robotic she said oh according
to the polls
and the world realized dude you're not
obama okay stop trying to be obama
you're not obama you're not even in
one-tenth of obama she's not bill
however strategically
dirty she's much dirtier than obama
obama's not
the dirtiest of dirtiest hillary's dirty
but obama's poised it's a big difference
yeah there's a very big difference
you know what are the other differences
when you look at dynamic between uh
barack obama and joe biden
barack obama is an alpha male i mean
look at you have to be
an absolute genius to go from a
community organizer
to have the audacity like you know his
book said
to think that you could become president
than a two-term president he's probably
running the show more than anybody else
on the democratic party
you look at joe biden he is a lap dog i
mean he literally is because he took the
easiest route you can possibly take
gravy training from one area and just
ride in that senate wave
and then allegedly potentially having
your son broker some deals where you're
making a lot more money on the side
but i mean it's like a big it's almost
like a marionette i mean
joe biden is attached to puppet strings
with barack obama probably
you know telling him what to do on some
level i think that's why we're seeing
this increased profile for barack obama
because he knows he's gonna have a lot
of influence coming up in the next four
years how's salty you've seen that
um clinton george w
bush obama they've all kind of
are speaking in unison regarding covet
yep i don't know if you've seen this
lately they're kind of like
as the former president of the united
states former two-term presidents of the
united states
we are now speaking in unison two
democrats all republican here's what we
have to say
here's my question how salty do you
think donald trump is that he'll only be
a one-term president
and you have three two-term presidents
basically being like hit the road jack
like
emotions emotion wise you know because
trump's an emotional dude you can't
he's not all logic he's pissing vinegar
he's emotional
how salty do you think trump is that you
have these three presidents basically
saying here's where we stand
you ain't doing a good job buddy i think
it's low on his worries i think he's got
other things you don't think he's
thinking about what obama bush and
clinton are not saying
i honestly don't think he's spending any
time on that you know i i i would this
guy gets upset when rosie o'donnell
calls him out you don't think that's
before he was the president that was the
fact that this is a celebrity i don't
think so because i don't i actually
don't think he it's upset you know why
you know why i don't think gets upset
because it's been like that for four
years
what's new but now you have three
presidents which one of them has
supported him in the last four years
bush but in unison though they've always
been in unison against trump
which one of them has been in supportive
of trump in the last four years just
to see where the republican party goes
do you think bush voted for
trump last election 2016. yes
probably not because his brother what he
called the brother the family all that
you think
you think he voted for them i don't
think he did i don't think nothing's
changed he hasn't had the support of
them so
if you haven't had the support of a
community for four or five years what
changes nothing
i got support from the soyboy community
that's all i wanted they love you hey
guys
you know what if you guys agree with me
let me know on the comments here because
i i almost look at joe biden as the
accidental president
because there is no way that barack
obama selected him
based on anything else in 2008 other
than what's going to help me get
reelected
there was something about his background
the votes he could bring
he didn't even 2008 when when
barack obama ran for president had joe
biden as his vice president
he said re-elected you mean in 2012 well
no when he when he selected joe biden as
his vice presidential
running mate in 2008 he didn't do it
because he was so overwhelmed with
the you know just the brilliance of joe
biden he picked him to help him win the
election
because he could bring in some sort of
vote that's what every president does
when they pick a vice president my point
is in the last
that's why trump picked uncle bob so you
can get the white advantage
for eight years do you think barack
obama ever listened to
joe biden said hey i bet he treated him
like
the little brother and told him to shut
up literally do you
do you think dick cheney was ever told
to shut up by george bush no
so he's the accidental president right
now because he rode the wave of barack
obama
and if the perfect timing for him at the
age of 78 when he didn't even campaign
anyway going down the street by the way
we just got a real cool
good mother's er not stop and she keeps
doing anything thank you good mother we
like
she gave five dollars and she says
pelosi isn't smart enough to come up
with that strategy but hates trump
enough to find somebody who does okay
dorian navarata said question if we
defund the police i'm pretty sure the
police will start stealing money
[Music]
there will be more bad cops if they're
not getting paid which is classic and we
had another one from good mother a good
mother
obama is a perfect pup obama's a puppet
too people should pay closer attention
to hateful and resentful women in power
those are the ones pulling the strings
[Music]